This video is made possible by morning brew,
morning brewers and email newsletter sent out every weekday morning you'll wake
up with the most relevant,
curated and informative business news from Wall Street to Silicon Valley
delivered right to your inbox.
Morning brew cuts through the clutter of business and providing a quick and high
quality daily newsletter.
I've been subscribed for a few months now and the short emails that I get
everyday a genuinely interesting,
which is not an easy feat for me when it comes to business news,
but morning brew,
they absolutely deliver the best stuff every single day.
Whether you want to blood about startup news from Silicon Valley or investment
news from Wall Street's morning brew has you covered and it's quick and easy to
read with a cup of coffee in the morning or on your commute.
Click the link in the description below to sign up to morning brew.com and get
the most informative and witty business newsletter around and it's free.
And let's get into the video.
John D Rockefeller was a businessman who amassed one of the largest fortunes in
history.
He controlled the 90% of the oil in the country and at the time of his death he
was worth between 300 and $400 billion.
Today the name Rockafella is synonymous with wealth for this very reason,
and his legacy has lived on long after his death.
Today on biographics,
we tell the story of how a seemingly ordinary boy grew up to be the most
powerful man in the United States.
John D Rockefeller was born on July the eighth 1839 in Richford New York.
His mother aligns a Davidson,
had a total of six children.
His father,
William Avery Rockefeller called himself a traveling botanic physician.
This might sounds impressive,
but this was actually just a fancy name.
Very snake oil salesman.
His father ends the nickname big bill for his larger than life personality.
These types of salesmen knowing me,
sold fake products to people promising that they're so called elixirs could cure
practically anything.
They will be usually charismatic showmen who truly knew how to get people civics
I did about a product that they were practically begging to give them money away
while big bill was traveling.
Across the country,
essentially stealing money from unsuspecting victims.
He would spend some time in each town before catching the next train.
He started a double life with a woman named Nancy Brown and had children with
that just by being so good at his job.
Big Bill always seem to struggle with money and the never seem to be enough to
give a rounds.
When he came back to visit a laser and this six children,
John d Rockefeller,
it was raised by his father to never trust anyone.
Big Bill opened his arms to capture John when he was still just a toddler,
but when the boy jumped,
his father stepped back and let him fall on the floor in order to teach them a
lesson.
Bill would also trick John and his brothers by making promises he never intended
to keep,
just so we can get them to do extra chores.
Big Bill once said,
I cheat my boys every chance I get.
I want to make them sharp.
John Rockefeller was the oldest son in his family,
so he was the man of the house.
His father was gone as a child.
He would help his mother raised turkeys in that backyard so that they could sell
the meat they did on jobs for neighbors and for the most part,
they were forced to fend for themselves without much help from their father.
At one point,
Bill decided to come clean to both of his wives and revealed that he was
splitting his time between two different households.
He suggested that they all move in together as one big happy family.
This was big in me of course,
but it was not illegal in the United States at the time.
The moral anti-big and the act was passed in 1862 off to polygamy became more
prevalent among members of the Church of Jesus Christ of Latter Day saints,
but the Rockefellers,
they weren't part of the LDS church.
Now,
he must have truly been a smooth talker because he somehow convinced both the
laser and Nancy to agree to a sister wives situation.
The family,
they moved to Cleveland,
Ohio and they told their neighbors there's Nancy Brown,
was that a live in housekeeper,
had Rockefeller was disgusted by his father's behavior.
He swore that he would never grow up to become that kind of man.
He decided to save his money and never wasted on frivolous things.
He also became very devoutly religious in the Baptist church,
held himself to a high moral standard.
This difficult family situation was most likely why he chose to start working as
quickly as possible so that he could move out and start an independent life away
from his parents and his father's mistress.
He often said that his goal was to make $100,000 which is the equivalent of
about $3 million today and to live to be a hundred years old.
Rockafella attended Cleveland Central High School,
but he did not want to wait until after graduation to become a businessman,
so he drops out of high school and so could just one business and accounting
class at Folsom.
Imagine Talk College.
This was enough experience to get them a job as an assistant bookkeeper for a
local merchant Scald,
cure it.
And Tuttle on September the 25th 1855 when he was only 16 he gains a lot of
valuable experience at this job,
but the only trouble was that his bosses only paid him 50 cents a date even
after inflation that still only $13 and 36 cents which was nowhere near enough
to make a fulltime living even though they weren't paying him much.
Rockefeller was always extremely proud of the day that he got his first job.
He made September the 25th into his own holiday called job day and celebrated
the anniversary every year for the rest of his life like an a Rockefeller.
He had been friendly with the customers that Hewitt and Tuttle,
this Scaife and a great reputation around town.
He was always paying close attention to how everything works and he eventually
to them,
do all of the skills necessary to start his own business.
Since everyone in town knew him,
he managed to get a full thousand dollars loan,
which is worth over $100,000 today.
This was more than enough money to start trading in goods like,
hey,
meat and grain.
His business.
It managed an m $450,000 in the very first yet.
Now,
he didn't get to keep that money for himself of course,
because a lot of it had to go back into repaying the loan and business expenses,
but this was a great start to what would be a long and prosperous business.
Korea,
John Said,
God gave me money and he did not apologize for it.
In 1861 the United States broke out into civil war and Rockefeller felt very
strongly about being an abolitionist.
Rockefeller's younger brother Frank became wound very early in the war.
When John was drafted,
he actually paid a professional soldier to given its place that way.
He was able to continue running his business and contribute to the war effort.
At the same time,
he said,
I wanted to go in the army and do my part,
but it was simply out of the question.
There was no one to take my place.
We were a new business and if I had not stayed,
it must've stopped.
Believe it or not,
this was actually a common practice back then,
at least for the men who could afford it,
and by staying home he was also able to profit by selling supplies for the war
effort.
Today,
the oil industry is concentrated in the Middle East,
but back then it was heavily concentrated in the u s in 1849 a man named Samuel
care discovered crude island has property in Titusville,
Pennsylvania by the 1850s and sixties word spread,
which caused a huge boom known as the Pennsylvania oil rush.
Then we're moving to Pennsylvania hoping to strike it rich by setting up oil
rigs and tapping the grounds for their liquid of black gold.
At that time,
people needed oil for their lamps in order to see at night.
The only alternative was to process oil from whale fat,
but taking it from the ground was obviously a much easier process.
However,
the crude,
all that's found in the ground does need to be refined before it can be used by
a consumer.
Crude oil was being transported by train from Pennsylvania to various oil
refineries around the country.
John D Rockefeller had the brilliant idea of taking advantage of this rush by
building an oil refinery in Cleveland,
Ohio.
He was 24 years old at this point since he had decided that instead of
continuing to be a merchant,
he should devote all of his time and energy to growing his new oil business.
Rockafella he was still very frugal,
so he tried to save money by cutting out the middleman whenever possible.
Instead of buying wooden barrels from a third party company,
he bought thousands of acres of land so that has employees could cut down trees
and to make the barrels themselves in 1817 that's a man called Henry Flagler who
was interested in investing in Rockefeller is a business together.
They incorporated the standard oil company with Flagler's help.
Rockafella begins,
you buy up all of the smaller oil refineries in the Cleveland area so that he no
longer had any competitors.
Whenever any refinery refuse to sell their companies and Rockefeller would begin
selling as oil.
It's a loss.
So the customers would flock to him instead of the competition.
This would simply put the smaller companies out of business,
but he didn't stop.
That standard all began to spread to on the states and soon enough they were
refining 90% of America's oil.
He was now a million app at this point,
so the company was so huge,
it was impossible for one man to oversee the operations of the entire country.
That fall,
he decided to allow the former heads of the oil companies he purchased to become
his new board of trustees.
This created a super squad of the smartest oil experts in the country and he
made himself the head of this so called trust.
This sounds typical for blanche companies today who put her CEO as the
figureheads,
but back then,
this kind of empire,
it was unheard of and Rockefeller was setting the stage for other American
businesses as a leading example of how to acquire wealth and power.
In the 18 hundreds railroads were helping to eight America through the
industrial revolution.
For the first time in history,
large cargo could be shipped across the country record speeds by the 1860s the
two biggest businesses in the United States where the railroads and oil,
so it only made sense that Rockefeller wanted to be involved in both of them.
He was actually plotting to create a railroad trust and do exactly what he had
done with the oil businesses.
He was already cooperating with the Vanderbilt family and he was going off to
the owners of various railroads in order to purchase their stock and strike
deals with the presidents of each one.
Rockefeller needed to be on good terms with railroads because he needed them to.
Transport is barrels of oil by train.
Since he on such a massive quantity of product,
he negotiated with the Pennsylvania Railroad to get a discounted rate on
shipping.
Oh first this was working out really well and the Pennsylvania railroad went on
a spending spree to expand the railroad before long.
The discounts are they gave,
Rockefeller was no longer enough to cover their costs and it would potentially
bankrupt the company,
so they have to go back on that promise and raise the price instead of giving
in.
Rockefeller responded by laying his own undergrounds pipelines and he reached
out to work with other railroad companies.
Now the Pennsylvania railroad had just lost their biggest clients and their main
source of income.
In 1877 the Pennsylvania railroad started building that own all refinery so that
they could put that trains to good use.
After all,
the oil industry was their bread and butter,
whether it came from Rockefeller or not.
Since Rockefeller,
it felt in a titled to control all of the oil.
He was outraged.
He stormed in to speak with the executives of the railroad saying why it is
nothing less than piracy.
To make matters worse,
the railroad employees began to strike across the nation because they were not
getting paid.
There's became known as the great railroad strike of 1877 they finally buckled
under the pressure and sold that oil refinery to Rockefeller for three point $4
million.
10 years later in the u s government would pass the interstate commerce act
switch forced regulations on the prices charged by railroads.
This prevented those companies from gouging the price of transportation.
From an outsider's perspective,
people did not see a railroad.
That broker contract.
They saw a Rockefeller as the villain.
People believed that he had far too much power.
Everyone could see the writing on the wall.
If Rockefeller was not stopped,
he may take over the railroad industry completely and after that there would be
no stopping him from taking more and more until there was nothing left for
anyone else.
The general public strongly disagreed with Rockefeller's tactics and they
believed that he was like a shock gobbling up smaller businesses is it already
happens in the oil industry and he was making moves in the railroad industry as
well.
People were terrified that he would eventually be so rich and powerful that he
might just take over the world newspapers.
They bashed standard oil and its political cartoons featured Rockefeller on a
regular basis.
Even President Teddy Roosevelt was very vocal about being antitrust and promised
Americans that he was going to do something to stop it.
The states of Ohio plan to create a new antitrust laws specifically to stop a
Rockefeller and standard oil from having a monopoly over the entire industry.
Since it was only a state law at that point is Rockefeller was able to
reincorporate in New Jersey in 1882 before they even had a chance to sue him.
He opened his new headquarters on Broadway in New York City.
Reincorporating in another state did not protect him for long though because in
the 1890 u s congress passed the Sherman Antitrust Act,
which made it illegal in every state.
Two years later,
the Supreme Court declared that standard oil was violating this new law.
So how did Rockefeller deal with dissolving his monopoly?
Well,
he didn't see,
just figured out a legal loophole.
The board of trustees,
they divided up standard all amongst themselves and created smaller companies so
that technically they would no longer be considered a monopoly.
In 1899 these new companies were all brought back under the umbrella of standard
oil.
These are called subsidiaries,
which is when a small company is under the control of a logical operation.
Just a few examples of these smaller companies where BP,
Exxon,
Conoco Phillips and Chevron,
these companies all around to this very day.
Oh,
that's fine.
There was a group of writers and journalists.
It's called a muck rakers and they took it upon themselves to uncover corruption
in American businesses.
One such journalist Ida Tarbell wrote a book in 1904 calls have a history of the
standard oil company where she went through the story of Rockefellers ruthless
rise to power.
She wrote,
Rockefeller and his associates did not build the standard oil company in the
boardrooms of Wall Street banks.
They fought their way to control by rebates and drawback,
bribe and blackmail,
espionage and price cutting by ruthless efficiency of organization.
Toggle is remembered for being one of the most successful investigative
journalists of her time and many credit hire and the other muckrakers with
helping to dismantle the Rockefeller monopoly.
Burt,
of course,
people in the general public.
They didn't realize that these new old companies were not small business making
a comeback.
Rockefeller,
of course,
was still pulling the strings and for him our rows of another name was just a
sweet.
Even though there is plenty of information out there about the financial success
of John d Rockefeller,
he was a fiercely private person and he tried his best to keep his family life
out of the newspapers.
What we do know is that when he was 25 years old in 1864 he married a woman
named Laura Spelman.
She was a devout Christian who worked as a school teacher and they were very
much in love with one another.
He said of her,
her was always better than mine.
Without our keen advice,
I would be a poor man.
He wrote a beautiful love letters when he had to travel for business.
He once wrote,
what a blessing that I have such a good and true wife,
how much I would give for wings to reach you tonight.
All of this romance led to the creation of their children,
Elizabeth Alice Alta or you death,
and John Jr Sadly,
Palestine during infancy,
even though he was very busy,
he always made time to be with his family.
He was a loving father and a devoted husband who never took them for granted.
Now,
all his life,
Rockefeller had a very impressive mustache,
but during the 1890s he began suffering from a condition called alopecia.
He began some news,
all of the hair on his entire body,
including his eyebrows.
At first,
he tried to hide it by wearing two pays,
but as he grew older,
he decided to let people see him in public.
After had lost all his hat in the 1990s a biographer named Ron Chernow got
permission from the Rockefeller family to write a biography.
He learns by speaking to his children and grandchildren that Rockefeller never
spoke much about his father,
and he never allowed big bill to be a part of their lives.
They also never met his half sisters and they were never given any of the
fortune because Rockefeller did not consider them to be a part of Israel family.
After digging through a mountain of paperwork or Ron Chernow finally found
William Avery Rockefeller's grave and a small cemetery in Freeport,
Illinois.
He was buried under an alias called Dr. William Levingston.
It would seem that even in death,
John d Rockefeller wanted the memory of his father to be entirely forgotten.
Okay.
In 1897 and John D Rockefeller chose to retire from his position at Standard
Islands,
left the control of the business to his board of trustees and to son John D
Rockefeller Jr in 1911 standard all was sued once again for violating the
antitrust actions.
They were forced to split out into dozens of different corporate entities,
but he decided to invest in all of these new companies and it's ironically,
it's only made him more money on the stock market.
Estimates on Rockefeller Seniors,
true net worth vary anywhere from 300 to $400 billion and they give that some
perspective.
The founder of amazon.com Jeff Bezos,
who is currently the richest man in the world today is only worth $100 billion
only.
It's probably not a coincidence that Bayzos also practice the same exact method
that Rockefeller once did,
buying out smaller online bookstores during the expansion of amazon.com now,
most people,
they cry to vilify John d Rockefeller,
but he wasn't bad.
He believed in the Christian tradition of tithing,
so he had been giving a portion of his income to charity since he was 16 years
old.
He gave it $70 million towards the founding of the University of Chicago,
and he also helped create the Spelman college in Atlanta,
Georgia,
which was an all black women's school.
According to the New York Times,
Rockefeller gave away $550 million in charitable donations to scientific
research education as well as the Baptist church.
Rockafella became well known in his later life with the practice of giving dimes
to adults and Nicholas to children wherever he went,
even gave dimes as a playful gesture is wealthy men such as Tom Mogul,
Harvey Firestone.
One of the best examples of his generosity also doubled as his legacy in the
end,
1930 Americans with suffering off to the great depression.
John D Rockefeller was already in his nineties so he decided to use a huge chunk
of his fortune to build the Rockefeller Center in New York City.
It was called a city within a city because it had dining shopping,
apartments,
and even a movie studio.
The project created 40,000 new jobs during construction and people were
gainfully employed once all of the businesses inside the center where open the
project was completed in 1933 and today the Rockefeller Center has become an
iconic part of Manhattan,
especially during Christmas time.
Biographer,
Ron China,
Richard Rockefeller.
What makes it problematic and why he continues to inspire ambivalent reactions
is that his good side was every bit as good as his bad side was.
Bad.
Seldom is history produced such a contradictory figure out.
John D Rockefeller Dye into just one year after completion of a center in 1934
he often told people that his goal was to live to be 100 years old,
but he didn't make it past the 97 perhaps the best way to summarize his life was
a poem Rockefeller wrote himself at age 86 I was at.
He taught to work as well as play.
My life has been one long happy holiday,
full of work and full of play.
I dropped the worry on the way and God was good to me every day,
so I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Also,
don't forget to check out our sponsor.
That's morning brew.
Find them below.
Just click that link.
Go sign up.
It's free.
Why not?
And as always,
thank you for watching.